.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Strahler Christoph Betschart
unterwegs mit seinem Bruder Thomas
auf dem Urner Tiefengletscher.
Dort oben fanden wir vor zwei Jahren
im Herbst eine Kluft.
Dann kam der Winter.
Letztes Jahr
kam sie nie aus dem Schnee heraus.
Heute gehen wir mal schauen.
Auch wenn die Kluft ihre Tücken hat:
Sie ist eine veritable Goldgrube.
Es ist immer schön.
Es ist aber auch schön,
einen schönen, kleinen zu haben.
Ein ganz kleiner Kristall
ist am Schluss der Grösste.
Der ist mehr wert als alles,
was wir heute gefunden haben.
Das ist schon lässig.
Das sind so Sachen, mit denen du
im Moment nicht rechnest.
Das macht es noch spezieller.
Dies ist die Geschichte des
Berufsstrahlers Christoph Betschart.
Auf über 3'000 m Höhe
verdient er sich seinen
Lebensunterhalt mit Kristallen.
Sein Berg: der Galenstock.
Das ziehe ich ihr nicht mehr aus.
Gell?
Zwei Monate vorher im Mai.
Heute beginnt für Christoph Betschart
die Strahlersaison.
Seine Familie sieht er
von jetzt an nur noch sporadisch.
Mit seinem Bruder Thomas geht es
tage- und wochenlang in die Berge.
Kein einfacher Abschied.
Ich glaube, es wäre falsch,
wenn man sich
keine Gedanken machen würde.
Wenn man das
einfach so machen könnte,
ohne dass es einen berührt, sollte
man vielleicht keine Kinder haben.
Im Winter geht es dann schon.
Die beiden sind ja toll.
Mit zwei Kindern
ist es halt schon strenger.
Es ist auch schön,
dass er wieder gehen kann.
Es macht ihn ja auch glücklich.
Aber ja, es ist ...
Es ist unser Alltag.
Wir sind es gewohnt.
Ja, wir gehen.
Tschüss!
- Tschau!
Es geht, nicht?
- Ein bisschen mehr bewölkt.
Zum Saisonstart im Frühling
geht es für zwei Tage
an einen Sonnenhang
hoch über Andermatt.
Ah, schön!
Für Bruder Thomas
ist das Kristallsuchen nur ein Hobby.
Enzian.
Profistrahler Christoph Betschart
ist auf gute Funde angewiesen.
Sonst kann er keine Familie ernähren.
Es ist jedes Jahr immer wieder
eine Reise ins Ungewisse.
Letztes Jahr hatte ich
ein paar gute Stellen,
von denen ich wusste,
was mich erwartet.
Dieses Jahr habe ich das nicht.
Ich habe schon ein paar Stellen, die
ich vom letzten Jahr noch weiss.
Wir werden sehen,
wohin es mich zieht ...
... oder wie das Jahr wird.
Das Kristallfieber erfasste Christoph
und seinen Bruder Thomas
schon in der Kindheit.
Wir gingen schon mit den Eltern
jede freie Minute in die Berge.
Einmal gingen wir dann
auch im Kanton Uri in die Berge.
Wir fanden ein paar kleine Spitzen.
Von da an war es passiert.
So wurden wir Strahler.
Auf 2'500 m Höhe
erreichen sie ihren Lagerplatz.
Wir können ihn so stehen lassen.
Gut.
Noch ein Gestänge rein.
- Ja.
Diese Hänge haben sie
schon viele Male abgesucht,
oftmals ohne Erfolg.
Und trotzdem
hoffen sie immer wieder aufs Neue.
Und, hast du schon etwas gesichtet?
Nein.
- Nicht.
In einer alten Kluft, die früher
schon mal ausgebeutet wurde,
gibt es eine Überraschung
für Christoph.
* Er atmet laut. *
Wie lange hält man es
dort drinnen aus,
bevor man wieder eine Pause braucht?
Zu Beginn des Tages etwas länger
als gegen Abend.
Es kommt darauf an.
Wenn es interessant ist,
übertreibt man ein bisschen.
Das spürt man dann am Abend.
Aber es schadet sicher nicht,
wenn man alle 30 Min. herauskommt.
Die beiden Strahler
erkennen anhand von Spuren am Fels,
wo es interessant werden könnte.
Schaut man sich
den ganzen Fels an,
sieht man überall diese Bankungen.
Sobald man genauer hinschaut
und etwas Quarz sieht ...
Es beginnt dort, zieht hier durch,
rund um den Fels herum
und geht bis hier.
Mal schauen.
Vorhin habe ich etwas gesehen.
Über Jahrmillionen sind die Kristalle
unter grosser Hitze und Druck
im Berginneren gewachsen,
so wie hier in dieser Kluft
mit Rauchquarzen.
Nur wer ein Patent hat, so wie
Christoph, darf sie herausholen.
Die Faszination des Strahlens ist
einerseits das Wunder der Natur.
Man nimmt etwas aus einem engen Loch
oder aus dem Dreck ...
... das von Natur aus
so perfekt ist.
Wir Menschen wären kaum imstande,
so etwas zu machen.
Auf der anderen Seite
ist es auch das ganze Drum und Dran.
Man ist draussen in der Natur.
Auch die Ruhe.
Doch, der ist gut.
Der ist schön.
Schön rein, die Spitze ist ganz.
Was heisst das? Was ist der wert?
50 Fr.
Ein Nachtessen.
Läuft es heute gut?
Ist das ein guter Saisonstart?
Ich bin zufrieden.
Es war auch schon schlechter.
Es kam schon vor, dass ich
Anfang Jahr nach 80 Tagen
noch keinen Stein gefunden hatte,
der ein Nachtessen wert war.
Das kann es durchaus auch geben.
Der ist jetzt wirklich schön.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Thömi, schau, es hat schöne!
Schön!
- Es hat schöne.
Doch, cool!
Gratuliere! Wow! Super!
Der ist schön.
- Super.
(Christoph) Den nehmen wir.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ein Skiunfall vor zehn Jahren
hätte Christoph Betschart
fast die Strahlerkarriere gekostet.
Nur dank einer Beinstütze
kann er überhaupt noch in die Berge.
Ich hatte einen schweren Skiunfall.
Mit Überschlägen wurde ich ein paar
hundert Meter hinuntergeworfen.
Beim ersten Überschlag
luxierte es meinen Unterschenkel.
Bei jedem Überschlag schlug es
den Unterschenkel hin und her.
Als ich zum Stehen kam und
runterschaute, erschrak ich.
Ich wusste, was das hiess.
Der Unterschenkel
schaute so in diese Richtung.
Der Fuss so nach oben.
Das Kniegelenk war hier drüben.
Da wusste ich schon,
dass das gar nicht gut ist.
Sie wollten mir das Bein amputieren.
Es war so viel kaputt.
Ich wollte das nicht.
Es wurde operiert
und gemacht und getan.
Ich muss schon sagen,
sie haben es sehr gut hingekriegt.
Sollte noch einmal
etwas passieren ...
... könnte ich nicht mehr
in die Berge gehen.
Zwei Jahre lang
musste sich Christoph Betschart
mit viel Reha zurückkämpfen, bis er
wieder sicher zu Fuss unterwegs war.
Hey, ich schlottere.
Essen tut gut.
Mhm, es ist gut.
Ist es gut?
- Ja.
Besser als im Restaurant.
Auf dem Berg ist immer alles besser.
- Ja.
Schau, ein Video!
Oftmals kriegt Christoph Betschart
nur via Handy mit,
wie es seiner Familie geht.
Bis zu 150 Tage pro Jahr
ist er weg von zu Hause.
* Sie spricht unverständlich. *
* Lachen *
Wenn man so etwas sieht,
würde man gerne dabei sein.
Aber wenn man dann wieder nach Hause
kommt, freut man sich umso mehr.
* Lachen *
Solche Schlitzohren
muss man ja vermissen.
Sie schlafen bestimmt schon.
* Gähnen *
Was meinst du?
Zusammenpacken und ins Bett?
Ich bin gespannt
auf den morgigen Tag.
* Sanfte Musik *
Und dann geht es wieder los.
Die Suche nach Kristallen -
ein spannendes Abenteuer.
Oftmals aber auch ernüchternd.
Das wären schöne, schlanke
Kristalle, wie man sie gerne hätte.
Aber es ist Chlorit dran. Auch wenn
man sie putzt, bleiben sie grün.
Sie glänzen nicht.
Solche Kristalle sind eigentlich ...
... für uns
nicht von grosser Bedeutung.
Grosse Funde sind eine Seltenheit.
Der Beginn seiner Karriere
als Berufsstrahler
verlief entsprechend harzig.
Die ersten Jahre musste ich mir im
Sommer einen Budgetplan aufstellen.
Ich hatte 2 Fr. am Tag.
Am Abend gab es Bouillon
und Couscous.
Das war es. Fertig.
Am Anfang musste ich auch mal
auf die Freundin zurückgreifen
und sagen:
"Hey, ich habe gerade kein Geld."
"Du musst mir
diese Rechnungen bezahlen."
"Ich kann die nicht bezahlen."
Nach zwei Tagen am Berg
geht es mit kiloweise Rauchquarz
zurück ins Tal.
Zu Hause in Andermatt
wartet die Familie auf Christoph.
Mit dem sechs Monate alten Vito
und der zweieinhalbjährigen Lynn.
Mama kommt auch mit.
* Lynn weint. *
Der Strahler packt mit an,
wo er kann.
Muss Dädi Vito halten?
Lynn, wie sehen
deine Schienbeine wieder aus?
Töchterchen Lynn
sucht oft die Nähe von Mutter Carmen.
Ein Preis,
den Christoph Betschart zahlen muss
für seine lange Abwesenheit
im Sommer.
Wenn man so lange weg ist ...
... merkt man schon,
dass die Mama mehr hier ist.
Aber ich habe damit nicht so ...
In der Nacht kommt sie dafür
eher zu mir kuscheln.
Das ist für mich ...
Das ist schon gut.
Sie hat halt auch eine gute Mama.
Ja.
Was?
- Wasser.
Möchtest du Wasser trinken?
Mitten in Andermatt liegt die
Werkstatt von Christoph Betschart.
Hier putzt und lagert er seine Funde.
Vor zehn Jahren hätte er
noch keine Familie ernähren können.
Doch mittlerweile zahlt sich
seine stetige Arbeit am Berg aus.
Doch, die sind gut.
Sie haben eine schöne Reinheit.
Man sieht den Finger.
Wie kann man davon leben?
Wie bei allem durch harte Arbeit.
Und als Strahler
halt auch durch Bescheidenheit.
Ich sage es immer so:
Früher nahm ich Ferien,
um Kristalle zu suchen.
Jetzt gibt es
halt keine Ferien mehr,
aber ich suche noch immer Kristalle.
Man kann davon leben, aber ...
Ich habe das Glück,
dass es bei mir aufgeht.
Ich habe auch das Glück,
in Andermatt sein zu können.
Durch den Tourismus
habe ich hier die Möglichkeit,
die Steine auch zu verkaufen.
Aber es ist
nicht selbstverständlich,
dass man
von den Kristallen leben kann.
Das funktioniert
nur bei wenigen Leuten.
Schweizweit gibt es
nur ein Dutzend Berufsstrahler.
Wichtig für Christophs
finanziellen Erfolg:
eine gut gefüllte Schatzkammer.
Hier sind
noch viele Steine vom letzten Jahr,
die ich noch zurückbehalten habe.
Wenn man eine Familie hat,
schadet es nicht,
eine Reserve zu haben.
Das war mir wichtig,
als ich eine Familie gründete.
Rücklagen müssen vorhanden sein.
Zwei Monate später im Juli.
Jetzt beginnt
die wichtigste Zeit für Christoph.
Von nun an wird er
jeweils sechs Tage am Stück
im Hochgebirge sein.
Schau!
- Was hast du gesehen?
Rutschbahn.
- Nein, das ist keine Rutschbahn.
Das ist keine Rutschbahn, Lynn.
- Das sind Förderbänder.
Für die Familie ist es
eine strenge Zeit ohne den Vater.
Man hat sich daran gewöhnt.
Sicher vermissen wir ihn.
Es gibt
auch immer wieder Situationen,
in denen man froh wäre,
wenn der Mann ...
... hier wäre,
um ein bisschen zu unterstützen.
Aber wir haben ja dann im Winter
wieder viel mehr Zeit miteinander.
Beine einziehen, Lynn.
Zieh die Beine hoch!
So.
* Lynn quengelt. *
Dädi geht in die Berge.
Wir drücken Dädi noch ganz fest.
Schau!
- Ja.
Tschüss!
* Er pfeift. *
Das Ziel
von Christoph und Bruder Thomas
ist der Galenstock auf über 3'000 m.
Seit zehn Jahren ist Christoph
hier auf der Suche nach Kristallen.
Und doch ist dieses Jahr
vieles anders.
Die grosse Hitze
hat bereits im Frühsommer
ihre Spuren hinterlassen.
Schau mal, wie der zusammenfällt!
Das Eis in dieser Höhe.
Voll übel, nicht?
Der Tiefengletscher zerfällt.
Der ist jetzt abgeschnitten.
Er ist nicht mehr verbunden.
Es ist Toteis.
Hier kann man jetzt zuschauen.
Den gibt es nicht mehr lange.
Er fällt in sich zusammen.
Es ist traurig, zuzuschauen.
Was heisst das für eure Arbeit?
Auf der einen Seite
ist es für mich ein Glück.
Weil das Eis zurückgeht,
kommt am Gletscherrand
frischer Fels zum Vorschein.
Boden,
der noch nie angeschaut wurde.
Dadurch kommt man
immer wieder an neue Stellen.
Andererseits stabilisieren
die Gletscher die Berge.
Wenn das Eis zurückgeht,
der Permafrost taut ...
... kommen die Berge in Bewegung.
Dementsprechend haben wir
mehr Stein- oder Eisschlag.
Das sind halt andere Gefahren,
mit denen man sich
auseinandersetzen muss.
Normalerweise ist der Gletscher
erst ab Mitte September schneefrei.
Nun zeigt sich das blanke Eis
schon Mitte Juli.
Der Grund:
wenig Niederschlag im Winter
und hohe Temperaturen im Sommer.
Oh, Eisschlag!
Hier liegt das Hauptrevier
des Berufsstrahlers.
Unterhalb des Galenstocks
beim Tiefengletscher.
Durch die Eisschmelze tauchen
immer wieder neue Kluften auf.
Der ist dick.
Schau mal da! Hier hat es ein Band.
Siehst du dort unten?
- Ich gehe mal in das Loch runter.
30-mal geht man in ein solches Loch
und es ist nichts.
Und dann hat man wieder Glück.
Man muss immer schauen.
Das sind Quarzbrocken.
- Wirklich?
Hat es Quarz?
Dort hinten hat es
einen grossen Quarz.
Ich träume immer wieder davon,
irgendwo ein solches Loch zu öffnen.
Man schaut 10 bis 15 m hinein
und sieht diese Gruppen
kreuz und quer dort liegen.
So etwas treibt einen an.
Man weiss,
dass es das hier irgendwo gibt.
Kommst du hier wieder raus?
- Was?
Kommst du wieder raus?
- Wo?
Willst du dort hinunter? Ich weiss
nicht, ob du da wieder raufkommst.
Du könntest ja runterkommen
und mir die Hand geben.
Lass aber keine Steine runter.
Alles gut.
Ich weiss nicht,
worauf ich hier stehe.
Ob es eingeklemmte Steine sind
oder nicht.
Mit den Beinen voraus
könnte ich schon hinunter.
Nein, spinnst du!
Geh dort nicht hinunter!
Da kommst du nicht mehr raus.
Nein, wir warten. Hab Geduld!
Man sieht,
wie es den Quarz herausarbeitet.
Sicher?
Dann behalten wir es im Auge.
Wenn wir es oben markieren,
ist es gesichert.
Pass auf,
dass du nicht zu viel bewegst.
Ich muss schauen,
wie ich hier hochkomme.
Hier oben nicht festhalten!
Gut, du kannst mich loslassen.
Hoch!
Christoph markiert die neue Kluft
mit Namen und Datum.
Zwei Jahre lang
ist sie so für ihn reserviert.
Zur Sicherheit
fotografiert er die Stelle,
damit ihm niemand
die Kluft streitig machen kann.
Ich habe es auch schon erlebt,
dass ich etwas markiert hatte
und ein anderer es wegschlug
und seinen Namen hinschrieb.
Aus solchen Erfahrungen lernt man.
Man macht zusätzlich ein Foto.
So kann man sagen:
"Wir waren als Erste hier."
Auch ganze Kristallgruppen
seien ihm schon geklaut worden.
Die war bis hier aussen
voll mit Kristallen besetzt.
Hier waren eher grobe. In der Mitte
stand ein hoher Spitz hervor.
Man sieht die Bruchstelle noch.
Alle schönen Kristalle wurden
abgeschlagen und der Rest zerstört.
Auch diese Zinken.
Hier hat einer so richtig geschändet
und es kaputt gemacht.
Im ersten Moment schüttelt man
den Kopf und ist wütend.
Man denkt:
"Das darf doch nicht wahr sein!"
Ja, sollen sie Freude haben.
Die Leute, die das machen.
Mir würde es keine Freude machen,
wenn ich so einen Stein abschlagen,
jemandem etwas wegnehmen
und es zu Hause ausstellen würde.
Schön.
- Tipptopp.
Ein wunderschönes Plätzchen.
Von zu Hause
hat man keinen solchen Ausblick.
Am Abend erreichen Christoph
und Thomas ihr Biwak auf 3'000 m.
Dies ist ihr Zuhause
für die nächsten drei Monate.
Aufgebaut hat es Christoph
in der Vorwoche.
Es ist schon friedlich,
hier oben zu schlafen.
Besser als am See.
- Möchtest du?
Nein, keine Tomaten.
Das Biwak ist komplett eingerichtet
mit Koch- und Schlafstelle,
Ersatzkleidern
und vielen Lebensmittelvorräten.
Viel Material
wurde selber hochgetragen,
der Rest per Helikopter hochgeflogen.
Ich nehme eine Wurst.
Schweinswürste.
Ich mache mal Kaffee.
* Ruhige Musik *
Fast wie die Steinböcke
sind die Strahler gewöhnt
an das Leben in Fels und Eis.
Doch: Es ist ein gefährlicher Job.
Christoph Betschart hat vor drei
Jahren einen guten Freund verloren,
der allein am Strahlen war.
Als dieser am Abend
nicht nach Hause zurückkehrte,
rief seine Lebenspartnerin
besorgt Christoph Betschart an.
Ich sagte, ich gehe mal schauen,
ob ich das Auto finde.
Wir machten uns auf die Suche.
Wir fanden das Auto.
Schnell merkte ich,
dass er an den Stellen,
an denen wir gemeinsam
gewesen waren, nicht war.
Ich alarmierte die Rettung.
Am ersten Tag wurde
bis gegen 23 Uhr nach ihm gesucht.
Es wurde dunkel.
Die Suche musste abgebrochen werden.
Das war die schwierigste Nacht.
Du wusstest nicht, wo er war.
Lebt er noch? Hat er Schmerzen?
Das war das ...
Am anderen Tag
gingen wir wieder los.
Er wurde gefunden.
Ich war nicht weit davon entfernt.
Aber in dem Moment konnte ich
nicht hin. Ich ging nicht schauen.
Ja, ja.
Hat dieser Tod
etwas verändert für dich?
Ja.
Dort kriegte ich
zum ersten Mal 1:1 mit ...
... was es mit den Leuten macht.
Ich dachte mir ...
Ich sah, wie schmerzvoll
es für die Familie war.
Jetzt,
wo ich auch eine Familie habe,
ist es
schon immer in meinem Hinterkopf.
Das möchte ich
meiner Familie nie antun.
Es hat mich insofern verändert,
dass ich an gewissen Orten,
an denen ich früher strahlte,
sagten musste:
"Nein, das ist es mir nicht wert.
Das lasse ich jetzt sein."
* Nachdenkliche,
melancholische Musik *
* "We Don't Need Another Hero"
von Tina Turner aus dem Radio *
Am Morgen
geht es hoch zu einer Kluft,
welche Christoph
vor zwei Jahren gefunden hat.
Von dieser
verspricht er sich einiges.
Und? Steine weg?
- Hat niemand gearbeitet?
Nein, alles gut.
- Super.
Wir müssen dann vielleicht
eher auf diese Seite hinausgraben,
damit das Wasser wegfliessen kann.
Sonst kommen wir nicht durch.
Schau! Siehst du?
Zu viel hier durch, geht nicht.
- Nein.
Im letzten Sommer
lag hier zu viel Schnee.
Zuerst muss Christoph
viel Geröll wegschaffen.
Und dies mit einer lädierten Hand.
Letzte Woche habe ich
einen Stein herausgerollt.
Leider war ein anderer Stein im Weg.
Das ist nicht so tragisch.
Was ist passiert?
Vor dem Gelenk schaute er
90 Grad in die andere Richtung.
Ich habe ihn gerichtet
und eingebunden.
Ich binde es so zusammen,
damit er gestützt ist.
Die Zeit ist so kurz.
Wenn man zum Arzt geht,
macht er einen Gips.
Man entfernt den Gips
und geht trotzdem wieder strahlen.
Daher lässt man es
besser gleich sein.
Es verursacht nur Kosten.
Unten in Andermatt
ist Carmen mit den Kindern unterwegs.
Von dort darfst du dann allein.
Auch wenn diese
ihre volle Aufmerksamkeit fordern -
in Gedanken ist sie oft
bei Christoph und den Gefahren,
denen er sich aussetzt.
Ich habe mir beigebracht,
nicht ständig daran zu denken.
Ich lenke mich ab.
Am mühsamsten ist es,
wenn ich einen Telefonanruf erwarte,
der nicht kommt.
Dann beginnt das Kopfkino.
Aber grundsätzlich
musst du vertrauen.
Carmen Betschart managt
auch den Verkauf der Kristalle.
Ein Teil davon liegt in Selbst-
bedienungskistchen am Strassenrand,
die teuren Stücke
verkauft sie im Internet
und im eigenen Laden mitten im Dorf.
Hier sind deine Steine, gell?
So.
Schätzchen, fahr jetzt nicht herum!
Warte, bis wir weitergehen!
Dann kannst du wieder fahren.
Mit zwei Kindern bist du gefordert,
nicht?
Immer. Komm, gib es mir!
Lynn!
* Vito weint. *
Vito, ich komme. Es tut mir leid.
* Carmen lacht. *
Entscheide dich, was du willst!
Eigentlich geht es relativ gut.
Manchmal braucht es etwas Geduld.
Sie ist halt schon ein Wirbelwind.
Meine Aufmerksamkeit
ist voll bei den Kindern.
Die Zeit drängt - eine Kundin
wartet bereits vor dem Laden.
Ganz fest stossen.
Danke!
- Gerne.
Ich muss die Tür schliessen,
damit die Kleine nicht abhaut.
Suchen Sie etwas Bestimmtes?
Eine Kollegin sagte mir,
dass es in Andermatt
diese tollen Bergkristalle gibt.
Carmen Betschart und ihr Mann
ergänzen sich bestens.
Während er die guten Steine findet,
sorgt sie dafür,
dass sie
zu einem guten Preis verkauft werden.
Er hat so viel Arbeit,
dass die Preise gerechtfertigt sind.
Sicher kann man
auch mit mir diskutieren,
aber er wirft einem die Sachen schon
hinterher, bevor man gefragt hat.
Das mache ich nicht.
Wir müssen davon leben.
Jeder Stein hat seinen Wert.
Und ...
... ja.
Ist das die Lampe vom Götti?
Schaltest du sie wieder ein?
Nein.
- Nicht.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Dass seine Frau stark gefordert ist
mit Kindern und Geschäft,
ist sich Christoph Betschart bewusst.
Arbeit und Familie -
eine anspruchsvolle Gratwanderung.
Wenn zu Hause alles gut läuft
und die Kinder gesund sind, geht es.
Wenn alles gut läuft, geht es.
Aber vorige Woche
waren beide Kinder krank.
Wenn man zu Hause anruft,
hört man die Kinder weinen.
Man merkt, dass die Frau manchmal
auch müde und am Anschlag ist.
Dann denke ich schon:
"Ich sitze hier oben,
sie ist unten
und ich kann ihr nicht helfen."
Ich habe zum Glück eine Frau,
die sich mitteilt.
Sollte es zu Hause gar
nicht mehr gehen, würde sie sagen:
"Christoph,
jetzt musst du nach Hause kommen."
* Ruhige Klänge *
Christoph und Thomas
sind zurück bei ihrer Kluft.
Wollen wir mal tauschen?
Ich kann auch mal meisseln.
Kollege, wollen wir tauschen?
Sonst schmerzt deine Hand morgen.
Die stundenlange Plackerei am Fels
setzt ihnen zu.
Komm, wir tauschen!
Lockere deine Hand!
Sonst schwillt sie an.
Das bringt nichts.
Und dann - endlich:
Das ist ein schöner Mocken, oder?
- Ja, der ist super.
Er ist ganz. Die Spitzen sind dran.
Das ist super.
Das gibt es nicht immer.
Vielfach sind die Spitzen kaputt,
wenn sie Druck abbekommen haben.
Aber der ist ganz.
Was ist das für ein Gefühl,
einen solchen herauszuholen?
Es ist immer schön.
Es ist aber auch schön,
einen schönen, kleinen zu haben.
Es ist rutschig.
Ich habe keinen Grip.
Über 50 kg schwer
und rund 1'000 Fr. wert.
Doch es kommt noch besser.
Ein bisschen wie Goldwaschen.
- Ja.
Oh!
* Er jubelt. *
Hast du ihn?
- Ja.
Was ist es?
- Ein geschlossener Gwindel.
Und was für einer.
Perfekt.
Er hat eine extreme Drehung.
Ha, ha!
Was ist so speziell?
Das ist
eine ganz seltene Form von Kristall.
Schau! Er ist gedreht.
Siehst du die Drehung in der Achse?
Das ist die seltenste Form
dieser Art Quarz,
die man finden kann.
Das ist eine grosse Ausnahme.
So schlank und schön, wie dieser ...
Ich habe auch schon schöne gefunden,
aber so einer ...
Ah!
Gib ihn mir!
Ich gehe hinauf.
Dieser geschlossene Gwindel
ist 5'000 Fr. bis 10'000 Fr. wert.
Und so geht eine erfolgreiche
Arbeitswoche dem Ende zu.
Beladen mit Dutzenden Kilo Steinen
und einem wertvollen Gwindel
im Gepäck
kehren die Brüder zurück ins Tal.
Mitten auf dem Weg
eine weitere Überraschung.
Hallo!
Hoi, du!
- Hoi!
Schau, wer auch hier ist!
Dein Götti.
Das sind coole Bergschuhe.
Hallo!
Ist der Chef am Schlafen?
Hoi!
Sali, Vito!
- Er schläft.
Ging alles gut?
- Ja.
Gut.
Alles Dädi den Rücken runter!
- Mama will auch noch Wasser.
Wie ist es, wenn die Familie
dich zum ersten Mal abholen kommt?
Das ist schön.
Daran könnte man sich gewöhnen.
Meistens sind sie im Bett,
wenn ich nach Hause komme.
Es ist schön.
Ich hatte Tränen in den Augen.
Jöh!
Der Traum der Betscharts ist es,
künftig als Familie
nach Kristallen zu suchen.
* Sie singen. *
Und neben der Wiedersehensfreude
steht der grosse kleine Fund
im Mittelpunkt.
Willst du das auch auspacken?
- Ja.
Shit.
Krass.
Schau, Vito!
Ist das ein Kristall?
Die Betscharts,
eine Familie im Kristallfieber -
und die Berge sind ihre Arbeitgeber.
Einsteigen! Und dann?
- Ich möchte ein Guetzli.
Aber schön hinsitzen.
Dann kriegst du eins.
In der nächsten Folge
steht die Hörnlihütte am Fuss
des Matterhorns im Mittelpunkt.
Die Hitzewelle hat begonnen.
Die hohen Temperaturen
setzen dem Berg zu.
Eine Herausforderung
für die Hüttenwarte.
Wenn die Temperaturen so bleiben,
besteht die Gefahr
von vermehrtem Steinschlag.
Dann müsste man
die Situation überdenken.
Das erste Hitzewochenende des Sommers
am Matterhorn.
Dies und mehr in der nächsten Folge
von "Hoch hinaus".
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2022